I remember another time I was in a hot
tub and this is on a cruise last year I
went on a cruise with the Impractical
Jokers these guys they're jokesters and
they're our friends and they have a
cruise and I went on there and and I was
in the hot tub right in the morning and
had a boy got in and this boy maybe 11
11 or 12 a thicker boy you know looked
like he was maybe from Nebraska or North
Texas you know thick kind of pasty you
know kind of nice kind of long hair
though a little numb in the eyes you
know a little polish you know kind of
like me I'm a little bit I mean I am
polish I'm polish Nicaraguan but I'm a
little numb in the eyes you know coming
in you know I'm coming in about 70 watt
and this boy was similar to that he was
seemed a little dull you know like they
hadn't fully like you like the like the
electrician hadn't visited his genetics
you know he was just a little bit dim
you know like maybe his
great-grandmother was as also his
great-great allant you know where there
was some somebody not walked far to [__]
at some point in his genetic history
there was maybe some light inbreeding or
just local seed that had been passed
between wombs somewhere along his
lineage but anyhow he's in the hot tub
and I'm in the hot tub this was early in
the morning you know I'd gone to the gym
early because my legs hurt and and I
don't like it when my legs hurt I like
my legs to feel regular like I like to
not feel them because that's the thing
if your legs hurt then they hurt but if
they're not hurting you just don't feel
your legs they're just there and you
don't feel them but um but anyhow I'm in
the hot tub and this fella he'd been in
a contest or something the day before
and he's wearing like a little bit of an
outfit he and I'm like a cape kind of
like a party cape
you know just like a and you know a cape
like a huge bib kind of that's on your
back for superhero [__] and he was you
know he was and he had some I'm Sam I
paint I makeup or something by his eyes
like he'd been a dressed up the night
before at a costume type of deal and
anyhow this fella starts tickling me
right tickling me
excuse me having some coffee oh this boy
starts tickling me and you know I never
really did like being tickled dude in
fact I told a girl that I was hanging
out with recently she goes are you
ticklish and I said if you tickle me I
will punch you in the [__] face
because I've never enjoyed it
I don't like being forced into painful
laughter immediately I don't like it
you know I like to have a little bit of
an inkling that I want to laugh and then
be laughing and not feeling that pain in
my body if somebody trying to jolt me or
just kind of trying to get into your
spirit you know and you just you just I
don't like it I feel I don't know it
just seems like something and see I
don't know uh some people I would like
to take I'll love to tickle the Chinese
man think about it think about the
Chinese right now literally visualize
them in your head
now think about tickling them dude think
about tickling them how cool is that
cuz they're active man and they're gonna
be fired up and and now okay nothing
about tickling a Japanese person kind of
cuter you know cuter well you know
Chinese I Chinese be more aggressive and
and they'll that Chinese will strike the
Chinese will strike dude if you haven't
spent much time around the Chinese they
will strike bro they are oh they are
they're just like termites in a way and
I don't mean that in a negative
connotations and we'll take that out I
just mean it in they are aggressive and
they get it done and they'll eat
anything and they keep going and and you
wouldn't be surprised to find them in
the wood in your house dude
the Chinese are plentiful I'll say that
and so this boy is tickling me right and
he starts tickling me and I don't know
him first of all I understand tickling
people you know you know people do that
tickling somebody you don't know uh [__]
no bruh you know that's way too much man
way too aggressive and so this fellow
was tickling me and I'm trying to keep
him off of me right and he had kind of
you know that paste he sort of
rubenesque kind of skin you know kind of
thick kind of I had some kid titties on
him you know what I'm talking about and
some kind of push him off but not push
him because when I was touched him I
realized I'm leaving handprints on his
chest so this boy I'm trying to fend him
off and he's coming at me you know and
he's coming at me bro and he's tickling
and he's then he had one of his feet up
even he was flexible under the water
above the water he looked unflexible he
looked like a damn just like a piece of
[__] white furniture you know
something you'd see in Sweden or
something that like a damn castle like a
Disney Castle he looked like a piece of
damn he looked like a [__] little
marshmallow loveseat you know but under
the water
agile and just just like a dim just like
a damn eel or a Griffon you know and he
just and he brought one of his legs up
and was tickling me as well with his leg
right so this boy has both hands one leg
up tickling me and I'm trying to keep
him off me it's just me and him in the
hot tub it's 7:00 a.m. so people are
kind of drinking their coffee coming
outside you know bringing bowls of
breakfast out pieces of fruit and small
you know small breakfast plates and
stuff like that
shareable plates you know small stuff
slices of um what else was it
grapefruits and anyhow so me and him are
set and they start kind of looking over
like what's going on and I'm trying to
push this boy off of me and I'm starting
to leave these fingerprints and and
because he's hot the waters made him hot
this is a hot tub and I'm leaving
imprints on his chest and on his you
know neck and it's people are looking at
us and then the secured is a security
guard you know doing his rounds or
whatever he starts looking at us and act
acting like what's going on and I look
and again I don't know this boy okay
imagine somebody you don't know
now imagine that they are tickling you
in a hot tub while people are trying to
eat breakfast nearby dude what
that's not even normal that's not normal
and and I'm leaving marks on his body
cuz I'm pushing him off and now I'm kind
of fighting him you know kind of pushing
him under the water and he's a strong
boy he was strong felt like a dam like
it just I was just pinned against a wall
by like a Dodge Neon you know and and
the security guard comes over and fine
and is like what's going on he's on his
walkie-talkie and the security guard on
a ship on a cruise ship it's just the
bartender from the night before you know
but now he has a walkie-talkie you know
they just recycle everybody so I'm like
looking at the dude and he knew I'd been
drinking the night before so now I'll
probably look like a damn unsuccessful
pdf-file you know so I just got out of
that deal I'm going back to sleep man
but you got to be careful on cruises
good evening good afternoon and other
times thanks for watching that video you
just saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one